we're not really taught a lot about
money in school not at all mean I think
we massively inherit money blueprints
from our parents people weird about
money as well right like people have
very strange attitudes about it most of
the time it doesn't make logical sense
people just kind of have these beliefs
and fears and things around money that
you kind of inherit from the people
around you when you're young you don't
talk about it at least in my family we I
don't think most families you end up
talking about it and then at school we
might have had like one lesson once
about something to do with it but that's
about it lots on oxbow lakes and stuff
like that but nothing on actually be
useful and so you never really learn and
so you end up in this weird position
where you reach adulthood and suddenly
you're spending like at least a third of
your life pursuing money you don't
really know what it is and you're
expected to make all these decisions
about money and people are talking about
mortgage rates and swap rates and bond
yields and this and that and the other
it's like and you're just expected to
know what it all
means